churches are america's favorite place
for redemption and sixth favorite place
for chicken churches are a cornerstone
of american life there are roughly 350
000 congregations in the united states
and many of them do
great work feeding the hungry clothing
the poor
but this is not a story about them this
is about the churches who exploit
people's faith
for monetary gain and when i say that
you probably think of 1980s
televangelists like
this guy i'm just getting into a
prophetic vein
digestive tract problems quickly
we've seen midgets grow we've seen arms
and legs that stop growing
because the gross cells have stopped
manda i don't make this stuff
up what plea please you can't say i
don't make this stuff up
just five seconds after you said the
words manda casabasanda
that man is robert tilton and though he
like many televangelists was caught up
in an expose decades ago he never really
went away
healing go into those knees arthritis go
in the name of jesus tumors
go in the name of jesus that one calling
with lupus lupus you foul devil
you bow to the name of jesus lupus
you bow to the name of jesus you go
in jesus name lupus you complicated and
not especially easy to describe malady
you go
lupus you vectors with your foul
looplessness you go
now though you may not be aware of it
televangelism is still
thriving in this country and robert
tilton is just a very small part of it
there are several large media networks
devoted to televangelism including
trinity
inspiration ministries and day star and
the preachers that appear on them can
have
incredible lifestyles just earlier this
year a man named creflo
dollar got people's attention with a
bold request
pastor creflo dollar of the world
changers church international facing
harsh criticism after starting a
fundraising campaign
to buy this 65 million dollar
luxury private jet if i want to believe
god for a 65 million dollar plane
you cannot stop me you cannot stop me
from dreaming
you you cannot stop me from dreaming
it's not how you ask for 65 million
dollars
it's what you scream at your father when
he tells you you'll never be a broadway
dancer
i can do it dad i've got the music in me
but but here's the thing creflo dollar
wanting a private jet is not remotely
unusual
there is a pattern of preachers wanting
high-end airplanes and when they get
them
they're not always particularly humble
about it i had enough money to buy a
beautiful
citation jet cache
and since there's so much jealousy in
this room tonight
that i can feel over this a few weeks
later
i bought another one worth three times
what that one was
cash act happy over my blessing folks
i bought a jet cache i bought a bigger
jet cache the haters act happy for
me
that's that's not a sermon it's the
first draft of a rick ross single
now now creatures claim these planes are
vital tools look at kenneth copeland who
along with his wife gloria are among the
most successful tv
evangelists a few years back he asked
his followers to help buy a 20 million
dollar jet
promising it would only be used for
church business but a local news crew
did some digging
and what they found will probably not
surprise you
it was a news 8 investigation last
february which first raised questions
about
copeland's apparently personal use of
his new church jack
this is a preaching
machine most notably for a ski trip to
colorado
and visits to an exotic game ranch in
south texas here's copeland and his son
john proudly posing with a pair of axis
deer
indigenous to india and sri lanka holy
this guy's like a psychotic reverse
noah two by two male and female
came to kenneth copeland and he doth
shot them right between the eyes
now copeland's ministry will tell you
that he reimburses the church for trips
like that but that still means
he has private jets reimbursement money
and yet despite that personal wealth
people still send kenneth copeland
creflo dollar
and that with two planes lots
and lots of money and that's partly
because they preach something
called the prosperity gospel which
argues that wealth is a sign
of god's favor and donations will result
in wealth
coming back to you that idea sometimes
takes the form of seed faith
the notion that donations are seeds that
you will one day
get to harvest let me show you that in
action the size of your seed
will determine the size of your harvest
i don't understand why but there's
something happens at a level
where people step into faith and give a
thousand dollars that don't happen at
other levels
you're going to have a breakthrough
through this 273 dollar seat
all you've got is a thousand dollars
listen
that's not enough money anyway to buy
the house you're trying to get in the
apartment
you're trying to buy the house that's
not enough money anyway
you get to that phone and you put that
seat in the ground and watch god
work it out the the argument is
sow your money in the ground and you
will reap returns multiple times over
except as an investment
you'd be better off burying your money
in the actual ground
because at least that way there is a
chance your dog may dig it up and give
it back to you one day
good boy but but it can get even more
predatory because if say
you don't have a thousand dollars or
perhaps have significant credit card
debts
seed faith can still work for you i have
a feeling
that somebody that wants a credit card
debt wiped out
that if you'll use your faith as you sow
as you sow the thousand on a credit card
as you use your faith
as you use your faith god's gonna wipe
out your credit card indebtedness
think about that that is the equivalent
of saying the key to you losing weight
lies at the bottom of this giant costco
bulk bag of peanut butter m
m's go find it it's definitely down
there
and all of this all of this would be
amusing
if the targets of these messages were
not often
vulnerable people like bonnie parker she
did not seek medical treatment for
cancer
instead choosing to sow money into
kenneth copeland's church
and i'll let her daughter pick it up
from there i started finding notebooks
how long after she passed away she
believed and i know she believed because
it's in the notebooks
that if she sowed enough seed which was
money
the greater amount of seed that you sow
according to them
um the better chance you have the better
chance you have of getting healed
at this point i think it's clear that
seed faith is the most disgusting
seed-based concept
since whatever the chia seed
pudding is
bonnie parker gave thousands of dollars
to the copeland's church because she
believed it was her best chance of
beating cancer and you might think
well that's crazy but it's not an
unreasonable interpretation of the
copeland's preachings
gloria copeland sells numerous products
on healing through faith
and has been skeptical in the past about
going to the doctor
we know what's wrong with you you've got
cancer
the bad news is we don't know what to do
about it
except give you some poison that'll make
you sicker
now which do you want to do you want to
do that
or you want to sit here on saturday
morning hear the word of god
and let faith come into your heart and
be healed
hallelujah it's pretty clear that woman
cannot hear the word of god because
if she could i'm pretty sure he'd be
shouting you
gloria right in her ear
and yes and yet not only
is everything you've seen so far legal
but the money people donate in response
to it
is tax-free because if you're registered
as a religious non-profit or especially
a church
you are given broad exemptions over
taxation and regulation
the irs in fact produced a scintillating
video instructing its agents how to
treat churches
and it contains a phrase that you would
not normally associate with the agency
hello and welcome to churches and
religious organizations
do's and don'ts for reasons as old as
the united states
the tax laws and regulations that govern
churches and religious organizations
are purposely broad and sometimes a
little vague
a little vague oh they are underselling
that because
the films of christopher nolan are a
little vague
a text from your mom reading please call
not emergency but please call very
important
don't worry that's a little vague the
irs regulations
are close to meaningless according to
their tax cuts not only is the term
church not specifically defined they
make no attempts to evaluate
whether the content of a doctrine is
religious provided
the beliefs are truly held and are not
illegal but truly helped beliefs that
are not illegal
is almost every belief bros before hoes
that could be a religion red vines are
better than twizzlers
that could be a religion if you believe
the best movie ever made is lady in the
water
then your name is m night shyamalan but
congratulations mr shyamalan
that belief could be a religion and
being designated a church confers
all sorts of benefits like the parsonage
allowance
which allows the copelands to live in a
6.3 million house
tax exempt this is their house that
is a parsonage which only makes sense if
by parsonage they mean
house that looks like it cost the net
worth of big bang theories jim parsons
we actually asked the irs how many
churches they've audited in recent years
and they did one in 2014
and just two in 2013 the odds of a
church getting audited are basically the
same as gloria copeland
curing your cancer and
and when you can operate here's the
thing
when you can operate with so little
oversight it is amazing what you are
able to do
look at robert tilton if you ever send
him a donation you cannot
imagine what happens and luckily you
don't have to imagine because
and we should probably come clean here
we
have been involved in a correspondence
with robert tilton's church
for the last seven months to try and
find out
what he tells people so settle in
because this gets
incredible back in january i sent him 20
and a letter asking to be added to his
mailing list within two weeks he sent me
a letter back
thanking me for my donation and claiming
i believe that god
has supernaturally brought us together
and supernatural is a bit of a stretch i
saw him on television and i sent him
some money he wasn't
my dead lover who came back to help me
with some pottery
but soon afterwards he sent me a second
letter and inside there was a one dollar
bill which was exciting
until i saw the inscription instructing
me to
send it back to him with your best prove
god tithes or offering
that's right i had to send the one
dollar back with an additional
recommended offering of 37
which i did so at this point we're just
two letters in
and already it's like having a pen pal
who's in deep with some loan sharks
this correspondence continued back and
forth like this until march
when he sent me three small packets of
colored oil that i was instructed to
pour on letters and send back to him
by specific dates along with more money
so i did that
and in april i got a letter in a manila
envelope with the message
check enclosed and i thought fantastic
i've seeded and i've seeded and have
seeded
here comes my harvest then i open it and
this is true
it was a check for five dollars from me
made out to pasta tilton's church
this went on for seven more letters and
then he sent me a piece of fabric
in the shape of some mountains i assumed
at this point i'd somehow reached the
mountain level
and surprise surprise he asked me to
send those mountains back to him
with some more money again so i did and
then he sent me another letter
with another single dollar bill inside
he told me to put that dollar bill in my
bible for one night
and then send it back the next day with
49 more dollars
so that he can have it blessed with oil
and send me a one dollar bill back
that has been blessed adding i must warn
you not to rob god with your tithes and
offerings
and then for emphasis i can't urge you
enough do not let this one dollar bill
stay in your house
and you know what i kept that one dollar
bill because him
that's that's right so that one i kept
that that one i kept but but
that did not stop him the letters kept
on
coming i received another oil packet
more prayer cloths
and even and this is true an outline of
his
foot which i was asked to trace my foot
on and mail back to him
with more money so as of tonight i have
sent him 319
and received 26 letters that's almost
one a week and again
this is all hilarious until you imagine
these letters
being sent to someone who cannot afford
what he's asking for
so at this point i was getting pretty
angry
and looking for a sign of what to do so
i watched
a little more robert tilton and the most
amazing thing happened
there's a person watching me and you've
been very
frustrated with your purpose
in life that might be me bob
because i'm extremely frustrated right
now as it seems my purpose in the last
seven months has been to send you money
through the mail so so i
i will ask what's that message that you
have for me
that's so strong just then just then
i had a word of knowledge for someone
that's really been seeking god you have
for a particular purpose or a decision
in your life
and that is when i realized the message
robert tilton was sending me was that i
should set up my own church
to test the legal and financial limits
of what religious entities
are able to do and so that
is what we have done we filed paperwork
last week
establishing a church called our lady of
perpetual exemption
and it was disturbingly easy
to make sure we did this correctly we
had this actual tax lawyer
walk us through the process now while
the irs does not have a definition of a
church they do have
a 14 point test as a guideline for
churches but not only do you not have to
meet all 14 points
we'd already met some of them by
accident for instance
you need an established place of worship
but
we meet every sunday in this studio in
new york
and apparently that genuinely counts
our lawyer also advised us our church
needed to be a distinct legal entity so
we we registered our church as a
non-profit corporation in texas
a state i do not live in have never
lived in but which is somehow completely
fine for us to incorporate a church in
now the irs's guidelines suggest you
need a creed and form of worship but
our lawyer suggested we could fulfill
the worship requirement by merely
leading everyone
in some specific ritual such as having
congregants
silently meditate on the nature of
fraudulent churches
so let us do
exactly that and bow our heads in silent
contemplation
and lo another box was ticked our men
and finally finally according to
our attorney the best case for church
membership
will be made by those individuals who
are actually present in the live studio
audience
who will profess belief in the church's
creed so what do you say live studio
audience
do you profess your belief i said do you
profess your beliefs tonight brothers
and sisters
then there is only one thing left for us
to do
let's go to church
brothers and sisters welcome to our lady
of perpetual exemption
i am your mega reverend thank you
brothers and sisters
your mega reverend and ceo john oliver
and can i tell you i
am so blessed tonight so blessed to be
joined by my radiant wife
wanda joe oliver please welcome
please
and praise be to all of you watching us
tonight or joining us online at www dot
our lady of perpetualexemption.com but
most of all praise be to the irs
that most permissive of government
agencies wonder joe
i have heard the word of prophecy
hallelujah
what did it say my job i'll tell you
i'll tell you mawanda
it says the viewers at home must plant a
a seed
an almighty yes preferably in the form
of cash although we do take checks
it it can be five dollars it can be ten
dollars it can be seventy seven dollars
we need you to sow
your biggest seed that's that's money
don't send a seat that's right wanda
please do not send us
actual seats because we ain't interested
can you see
we ain't interested we ain't interested
please send us
your actual money to this address at the
bottom
of your screen if you do this and this
is real great things will happen to you
and that's apparently something
i'm allowed to say praise praise legal
praise our tax attorney praise loopholes
in all their blessed loopiness
let me let me talk to the brothers and
sisters at home do you have debt
dead begone do you have lupus
a demon plague touch touch your hand to
the screen right now
and we shall cure it touch your hand to
cursed you cursed you demon lupus be
devil us no more
hurts you lupus you you probably didn't
even know that you had lupus
but you did but you don't anymore it's a
miracle
it's a miracle it's a miracle tonight
do not delay call this actual number
right now 1-800
because amazingly all of this is this is
all
legal call this toll-free number and
plant your seed plant it deep in him
okay plant your seed in his mouth plant
it all over it
okay one got one keep it together wonder
keep it together
gracie gracie call this number sow your
seed and ye
shall prosper what wonder wandered
do you feel the spirit do you feel the
spirit
[Applause]
do you feel the spirit at home call the
number on your screen
right now call this number
[Music]
truly we have witnessed a
miracle tonight